how old are you
well what we're doing is we've taken
swift precautionary steps we don't fully
understand this new variant at all yet
it's got 50 mutations roughly
of which 32 are in the spike protein the
bit that connects the key to our cells
and infects us so that is concerning
but it's still early days in terms of
understanding how it actually reacts in
terms of transmissibility in terms of
how dangerous it is therefore let's let
the scientists do their work but we've
taken some proportionate measured steps
to help slow down the spread and the
seeding of that variant while they do
their work hopefully it won't be
a huge concern but we don't know we've
got to be precautionary in this south
african medical association the chairman
of that saying the symptoms are very
very mild well i did see that report and
i think that um that doctor was talking
about
uh symptoms in predominantly younger
people that they'd experienced it in we
don't know how it will react in terms of
older people or with the vaccine so
hopefully that is what we will see
not just in south africa but around the
world but we've just taken those
precautionary steps while we seek to
understand how it works is it about now
when we think you know what we should
have given them more of the vaccines uh
for kovacs we've only given 11 of what
we promised well if you look at south
africa i think um the president of south
africa or government officials have said
there is no shortage of vaccines in
south africa
which is where we've seen this new
variant i'm originating from the greater
but but then if we're looking more
broadly and i think you and i spoke
about this um when last you interviewed
me
we've pledged 100 million doses by next
june we've delivered i think you're
absolutely right about 11 of that so far
we're on target to deliver just over a
third of that uh have delivered over a
third of that by the end of this month
and then we will deliver the rest next
year i think that's a
um a reasonable and swift roll out and
we're still i think the second biggest
donor supplier of vaccines through the
kovacs vote program after the united
states i think so can we do more and do
we need to ramp it up yes but are we on
target to deliver on that pledge yes we
are okay so let's talk about what's
going on at home then give us an update
this morning how many cases have we got
so there are three you'll have seen in
the news overnight three confirmed cases
i'll be honest with you and your viewers
i would expect that to rise um we don't
know by what speed or by what numbers so
therefore what we're doing is trying to
slow it down but we're clear we can't
stop it
and we're trying to give ourselves the
time to understand how it works and how
it interacts
with the vaccine but that's why we're
putting in place these sensible
precautionary measures to help slow it
down you say slow it down but the
flights were coming in from south africa
people were allowed to get off the plane
mingle with hundreds of other passengers
coming from wherever and then go home we
saw in amsterdam people were isolated on
the airplanes and they had their checks
before they were allowed off well i'd
say i think we've moved possibly
globally among if not the fastest
countries in the world i think south
africa identified the genomic sequencing
on tuesday
on thursday even before this was
designated as a variant of concern which
happened on friday i think from what on
thursday we'd already set out my boss
sajid javid had set out um very swift
steps to tackle this both in terms of
borders but also in terms of the plans
around um around testing and piecing so
i think we might have to get off the
plane i think we moved very swiftly when
people were returning or were in flight
um they were met by health officials um
we would expect them to travel to take
that pcr test and of course now we've
got the 10 countries i think it is on
the red list we will be expecting people
before they travel to have booked a
quarantine hotel so i think we moved
very swiftly proportionately but swiftly
and tackled that what there always is
which is the moment you make an
announcement like this
there are calls for people from people
for you to delay it to give people more
time they're others saying do it
immediately i think we've struck the
right balance here in providing that um
that that response but allowing people
to get home what about people who are in
south africa and other countries there
ready to come back and now they have to
pay 2 250 pounds to stay in a hotel
could be a family of four that's ten
thousand pounds that they don't have
what happens there well i think i do
appreciate that's extremely difficult
for people who will have gone on holiday
gone to visit family or gone for family
events
and suddenly find that this has changed
sadly we've seen over the past year and
a half year and three quarters this is
the nature of this virus we can never
with total predictability guarantee when
someone um travels abroad that there
won't be
something of this sort now we've managed
to avoid that largely in recent months
and the last new variant we saw we only
just came off the red list didn't it and
and yet some families now could be ten
thousand pounds in debt through no fault
of their own absolutely i'm afraid that
that's sadly and i'm very sympathetic to
that but that's sadly the nature of this
virus and what it does
you're right it did come off the list
pre the identification of this new
variant we've always been clear that was
a risk the new variant um credit all
credit to south africa for its amazing
genomic sequencing and testing program
that identified this new variant very
swiftly and they told us they told the
world they were very open about that
and they've been exemplary in how
they've done that but sadly until we
understand it we've got to take those
penalized for being so open well i don't
think they're being
penalized for being open we've seen with
other countries when are variants
identified we've got to take as have
other countries the necessary steps to
help stop that seeding and spreading
other countries i think have been even
tougher on some of their board
restrictions i think i may be wrong that
israel has closed its borders
overnight and other countries are
putting in different levels so each
country is reacting in its own way we
believe that we've reacted in a
proportionate and measured way um to
help address the challenge of this event
while we seek to understand it so what
else are we doing here
the booster program what's going on so
the beast program the secretary of state
sergey javid as you will know has asked
the jcvi the joint committee on
vaccinations and immunizations for
advice urgently on a the uh
bringing down the gap potentially
between
first uh between second and booster jabs
but also in terms of whether the booster
program should be extended downwards in
terms of age range we're awaiting that
advice i hope it will come hopefully
later today i don't want to pre-judge it
i don't know one so our understanding is
that it's anybody over 18 gets a booster
but i think that's what they are looking
at i don't know what they're going to
recommend it i haven't seen the advice
you you and your team may have done but
i haven't yet because i don't think it's
been formally delivered but we'd expect
that within the next within the coming
hours okay so so sometime today we'll
hear from that's my what's happening and
the gap between the second booster and
the second vaccine and the booster that
could come down to five months
potentially but we'll wait for their
advice that's that's what they're there
for and we will look very carefully
advice they give us hopefully in the
next few hours okay um
as far as the symptoms are concerned we
don't how do we actually know
whether people have got the omicron
variant or it's the delta variant or
whether because the symptoms are very
similar they are and that's why we're
recommending we recommend people with
symptoms um you know you and i and
others will probably be taking lateral
flow tests if not daily every couple of
days or similar or regularly what we're
saying to people with symptoms is that
they should take a pcr test because the
pcr test gives the facility to do the
genomic sequencing that helps us
identify which are omicron which are
delta
the lateral flow test won't do that but
the pcrs will and therefore when people
have symptoms or if they test positive
on a lateral flow again that's why we're
advising a pcr test to allow for that
genomic sequence so why did we do away
with the pcr test for people coming back
from holiday
we reacted in what we thought was a
proportionate way to the level both the
threat and knowledge we had of existing
yeah this every time and again this
virus has shown us that we can't be
complacent which is exactly what you
were saying well we struck an
appropriate balance there we still had
the surveillance program which allows us
to genomically sequence um through pcrs
to understand where the new variants are
coming through and we have to strike
about this it goes back to your point
just now okay again about the price of
things the uh the ability for people to
go abroad on holiday we think we've
struck the right balance but when a new
variant comes along we got that through
genomic sequencing we're now using pcr
tests just to identify where that is in
the communi if it gets into the
community more broadly but particularly
for travelers coming into this country
so we were risking the health of the
nation because of cheap natural floating
i don't think we were risking it because
i think on the basis of why have we
changed on the basis of
on the basis of what we were seeing with
existing variants and knowledge of them
as scientists understood those existing
variants lateral flow tests and similar
were appropriate what we're seeing now
is a new variant
um while we seek to understand that over
the next two three weeks which is
hopefully all it will take for
scientists to be able to actually
understand transmissibility
how dangerous it is impact on vaccines
it's right that we use the pcrs to
better understand that genomic sequence
and where it may have spread in the
community as i say i would expect i'm
afraid more cases in this country but we
need to work out where they are um how
long do you expect the red list to be in
place for well we will we'll follow the
evidence but in three weeks time the
prime minister and secretary of state
so just shy of i think but um we'll
review
the mark wearing and the travel
restrictions
of course that gives that gives enough
time for us to see how this disease
behaves we know that you and i have
talked about it many times the lag time
between infection between
becoming ill between serious illness and
equally it gives the scientists time to
do that work on this so it gives enough
time to understand the impact of it but
people who book their christmas holidays
what are you saying to them cancel them
no what we're saying is follow the
they're all red uh
red list countries you know they're all
people shouldn't be traveling to
themselves difficult
in this context
cancelling holiday but what we've said
is if people are coming back from south
africa we've put in place the quarantine
hotels that's again from what you were
just saying quite rightly you highlight
that's a a big cost and i think people
will think about that very carefully
other countries
we've said um pcr testing etc we're not
saying cancel your holidays to france or
other countries but we have put in place
that proportionate um testing and border
control people who are going to a red
list country is on the red list at the
moment they really shouldn't be well
what i'd i'll be honest and i've said it
before is we cannot say what will happen
there over the coming weeks and
therefore going to to your earlier point
in traveling at the moment with this
virus particularly with a new variant
around there is an element of of risk
there for people so you review that
before three weeks we need to have the
three weeks in order to understand how
this new variant works i hope that the
the scientists and those researching it
will get more information more quickly
and actually one of the things we did
last week was we were
open as quickly as we could be with the
british people about what we were
finding even without fully knowing how
this new variant worked we wanted to
level the british people which is what
my boss the secretary of state did last
week mask wearing you you mentioned you
touched on that it's gonna be tricky for
your boss isn't it your big boss he's
never wearing a mask i don't think so i
think um he will comply with the rules
um just as we all do i was when i was
sitting out um
when not being interviewed when i was
sitting out in your in your lobby
earlier i was wearing my mask took it
off to do interviews and then we'll put
it on again when i leave your studio i
think everyone will do that
for example in shops or when in shops or
on public transport that's what we've
said that's what we will be putting in
the regulations and we would expect
everyone to come why not in pubs and
restaurants i mean can you not catch
covered in a pub well equally in pubs
restaurants hospitality venues partly
we've always seen this throughout the
pandemic people are eating drinking etc
clearly impractical to wear a moss in
those circumstances say a restaurant a
lot of time is spent sitting down with
your group with whoever you've come with
family friends are in a pub should you
put your masters and ordering on that
again the li on that we're not making it
a legal requirement but people will make
their own judgments why not
because we believe that shops and public
transport often very confined spaces
take a ah to a london pub whatever it's
mad
taking well hang on i'll come on to that
um we think that's a proportionate
response it's a measured response while
we understand how this variant works we
don't believe
we need to or should they do that in
hospitality or restaurant venues at this
point and hopefully we won't need to
make any further changes hopefully in
three weeks we'll be able to scale back
um what we've done but we just
being honest we don't know how this
virus under the with this new variant
behaves yet so we've got to be measured
into this crowded pub standing at the
bar surely you should have to wear your
mask then no i think well if you're
standing at the bar chances are you're
ordering a drink and then drinking a
drink um and therefore you won't be
wearing masks while you're drinking your
drinks i think you go and get your drink
and then you go back to your table
but that's but you're only going to be
doing that for a brief period go to the
bar or your drink and come back if
you're in a tube on a bus you're likely
to be on there 15 minutes 20 minutes
half an hour and we go back you've been
interviewing me now for a year and a
half almost two years and when we were
first talking about this we talked about
both distance but also the length of
time you're in close proximity to an
individual therefore we think this is we
think this is proportionate and it's the
right precautionary balance to strike
okay we are out of time but um i mean i
have to have some sympathy for you when
when are we going to see the back of
this virus well i think the whole
country wants to see the back of this um
virus as satya javid said the pandemic
isn't over
yet and we've seen that with this new
variant but we are in a hugely different
place to where we were as chris whittie
said with any of the previous new
variants that vaccination program has
made a huge difference in protecting our
citizens protecting our society and
enabling us to open up and the measures
we're putting in place now as i say are
proportionate they're measured while we
understand how this works so i think
we've made huge strides forward um and
i'm looking forward to a christmas spent
with family and friends okay and finally
could we possibly find ourselves in a
position where you tighten the rules up
even further within the next three weeks
it's not something i'm anticipating oh
i'd like to hear that good to talk to
you thank you minister i really
appreciate